Keamy allows you to instantly make
duplicate copies of your keys by storing
a digital copy of them so you never get
locked out again and it'll open your
beer and the marshalled icicle is an
electric motorcycle concept that doubles
as amplifiers when instruments are
plugged in Vsauce Kevin here
this is mind blow
the cafe latte printer allows customers
to drink their own faces let's Cafe is a
kiosk located in Taiwanese convenience
stores that is offering customers the
opportunity to print any picture taken
from their phone instantly on top of
their latte
it works by dusting the image with an
edible powder using a
computer-controlled printhead and
they've successfully used it as a
novelty to increase business the live
map helmet was created by Russian
inventors to make a motorcycle helmet
with built-in navigation the helmet
creates translucent full-color images
and text in the visor
giving the writer the ability to check
speed time and get directions without
taking their eyes off the road like
traditional navigation it's only
slightly larger than a normal helmet and
adjust depending on the lighting outside
and they plan to sell them for around
$2,000 researchers at North Carolina
State University have created a device
that controls cockroaches using an Xbox
Kinect they created an interface that
sends the roach on a predetermined track
by using a computer to plot its course
researchers wire sensors to the roaches
external sensory organs causing it to
move forward and small charges in the
neural tissue tricks the roach into
thinking its antennae are hitting a
barrier causing it to turn scientists in
Japan cloned this Mouse from only a drop
of blood from the donors tail tokyo
flash created the key side watch that
lets users know whether or not they are
intoxicated through the use of a
built-in breathalyzer by blowing into a
hole located in the side of the watch
for five seconds the watch glows green
if it detects no alcohol yellow if
alcohol is detected but you are in the
legal limit and red if you are legally
drunk the watch also has a built in
sobriety test that asks the user to stop
a moving line at a certain point on the
screen sensoria are a pair of socks that
are able to track the way people walk
developed by heaps I lied by using a
Bluetooth enabled anklet in conjunction
with the socks the sensors in the socks
transmit the data to a computer or a
smartphone sensoria can determine
improper walking or running
Abbot's or if the foot is landing at an
unsafe angle during particular
activities and they're initially
targeting the device at runners Wi-Fi is
a prototype handheld device that
researchers at MIT have created in order
to see through walls users will be able
to point the device at walls and see
anything moving on the other side Wi-Fi
works by emitting Wi-Fi signals at the
wall where some of those signals bounce
off of the moving objects on the other
side and back to the device Wi-Fi could
be used in multiple applications
including aiding police and rescue
workers or creating better motion
controlled gaming systems archeologists
have recently discovered that flowers
have been used at funerals for 13,000
years this self bearing robot was
presented by the Carnegie Mellon
University robotics Institute in May of
2013 the plans to use self burying
robots range from mining to military
applications this robot is able to
travel to its location in one mode and
then bury itself in another shown here
digging through various things such as
rice sand flour and sugar but it's still
in the developmental stages and they're
trying to make more efficient versions
this bike helmet is made from recycled
paper pulp it was created by students
from the Royal College of Art in London
by making a pulp out of old newspapers
they mixed with an adhesive pigment and
organic additive they claim that their
rain proof for up to six hours and can
be recycled again after being used to
make more helmets though wearing these
may be better than no protection it's
still unclear the actual safety of these
helmets the termes project is developing
self-organizing simple robots building
3d structures based upon the building
abilities of termites the robot is able
to navigate lift blocks and build
structures much larger than itself and
the researchers at Harvard University
are looking into ways to further develop
automated construction finally minsu
Kim's living food project is a concept
involving food that moves on the plate
end in your mouth by building on
developments in synthetic biology
[Music]
I'm going to leave you with ping-pong
balls on fire and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]
[Music]